so this guy UFC Legend Colby Covington
he saw the video of LeBron James sitting
for the national anthem and uh he ain't
having it if you hate America so much
and and you don't like this country that
gave you a billion dollars leave it or
come deal with me go to China go to go
to these sweat shops that you employ all
these laborers and use these women and
pay them Pennies on the dollar to make
your Millions you L drama James you're a
coward you're a spineless coward and
you're a I want to get that guy on
the show like I don't know any I don't
really care about UFC or anything but
anyone that dresses like that the indoor
sunglasses you're
a